so i'm going to tell you a little bit
about the data set
the
the criminal court number 10
has a judge named paulo casas this
charge is really eager to open the data
of the court and also to produce it with
a gender perspective so we will find in
the data set a lot of columns that
indicates it's the if the resolution we
are seeing is from a gender-based
violence case
and we have a lot of questions we will
see later
a lot of variables that explain a lot
about the situation that the women lived
during the the the time of the
conflict
so the victim
so um
that's uh
really really important because we can
see some of the picture of the violence
that that woman or victims suffer
we
i want to say that
we think that not only women suffer from
gender-based violence
but most of the people that suffer from
it are women cis women and lgbt
community
people so
that's really important and it's
it's something we should keep in mind so
the data set
is in google drive so you can access it
really really easily it's a google
sheets actually we don't call it a
database
because
for a database it should be bigger and
it should be hosted somewhere else but
they have everything open they have the
resolutions they have the proceeding
manual they have the cvs the curriculum
of the resumes of the shuri lawyers they
have a guide for clear language
and they have the data set so you can
access it i will send the link for you
in a few minutes but also you can
access
twitter in
here and they have the link to the
google drive so it's really really easy
i never i never thought i was going to
be a fan of a criminal court but i am
i'm really happy with their work and
that's made is
partly a bias because i think
that um they do everything right
and maybe sometimes they won't but
we can see some examples in the data set
of things they should improve
but for me i think the work they are
doing is really really great
one small thing i will say later again
this court is based on buenos aires it's
a big city and there are 31 criminal
courts in buenos aires so this is one of
the 31 courts in buenos aires
so it's not the data is not
representative of the reality of
argentina for example
uh not even of buenos aires it's just a
small part of the city it's a big and
dense city so we have a lot of uh cases
and resolutions
uh but it's just a small part so you
keep that in mind
so these are the principles of the
chords i wanted to share with you
because i think they are beautiful
um
great so i will
try to
can you
mute uh
the participants are with the mice open
sorry
um okay
so
uh
i as
i was saying in latin america we have a
really really big problem with missing
data and we don't have a lot of data
about gender
issues
i come from an nco that works a lot
with gender data and we get a lot of
requests of do you have this kind of
data where you can find it and the
answer is we don't have it we don't know
and we have some small data sets that
are really good for working with some
issues but with other issues we don't
have it
so
we don't know how many uh
i don't know
women drop out of school
we don't have that kind of data
so
there are a lot of missing
data that we can't access
so
i just quick how to work with
gender-based data what is gender-based
violence
this is a phenomenon that affects half
the population
and it's a regard related to violence
directed against a person because of
their gender
um here in argentina
we have some laws that are really open
for
a transgender men and women
and non-binary folks so
that's really really good we know in
some countries that's not the case
um they suffer a lot of gender-based
violence too
and also
reinforces gender inequalities so we
think it's really really important to
understand better
what this is about and what happens
in the world not only in our region
and also to
put it there it's a human rights
violation
um we have it's a as i was saying it's
important to have quality data about
this to understand it better
uh we see
in the world that a lot of data is not
there around women issues
because it's not important if it's not
for selling us stuff or for reproductive
rights
so
we need to have this data to understand
better how it works and then we can
assemble some public policies to
attack it and to tackle it
so i encourage you to
look out there what you have in your
country what is legislation about this
in your country
what the reports worldwide say i'm not
going to get into that right now but i
will send you some links
and
what kind of data is available out there
so um
some things that you should
see when you
stumble up upon a
data set of gender-based violence
it would be really really good to know
some of these questions i don't know if
you will be lucky enough to have it but
how was the data collected what did they
choose those categories in each variable
for example um gender category
if it's man or women i
that
is a biological
sex but the gender identity field should
have more categories
and sometimes those categories are a man
women other
or men women
prefer not to say men women
something else and that's not really
accurate because we have
cis women cis men trans women trans men
non-binary and then the field of
preparedness to say or other
and it depends also on each country here
in argentina we have a group a community
of travesty people and in some countries
latin america travesty is a bad word and
people don't use it but here in
argentina they use it and they refer to
travesty as a gender identity so it can
vary between countries and that make it
not traceable between the countries but
we should uh keep in mind
uh that we can fine-tune these
categories for the analysis
and i think it's important for everyone
to be represented in the gender category
um when was it created what is the
meaning of the abbreviations is it up to
date what is the data used for who
financed the collection of the data
which was their purpose
everything
should be there and not
it's not there usually but it's really
important to have it
and also
to see i was talking before about my own
bias regarding this data set because i
really like the work that the shots is
doing and i i won't see many mistakes
because i'm kind of blind
about it
so
before
stay
working with this kind of that it's
important to ask ourselves what are our
our own bias
what do i think
i will find
and i will be looking for that or i will
be open to new findings um
of course this is a question everyone
should ask themselves every time they
are working with social data
but this is really important so i will
ask you for
to look inside yourselves and
think what is your own bias regarding
this data
what do you think you will find um
what what are your prejudice
do you think something is going to be
different because the data is from latin
america or from argentina than from the
rest of the world
i don't know i'm just putting some
questions out there and if you want to
write in the chat
uh something about what you think about
the the bias in in this data
in your cells in this data the bias i
was telling you about it
before
is uh it's partial it's not
representative of the whole
region
so that mainly
is going to
leave us with some
truncated
solutions or
reflections because it's not from buenos
aires or argentina it's from a small
part of the city and we have 31 a
criminal courts and this is one of them
by the way the rest of the courts are
not opening their data and they are not
doing anything remotely similar to this
one so that's why we are using this data
set
uh second we want to uh
emphasize that this dataset is a
really well curated for security and
privacy of the people
um the court works with a team of cyber
security and they
everything they put online previously is
encrypted and analyzed so it's not
possible to
to see the the the name of the person
where did they live in and everything so
it's really really secure and we should
be really conscious about this uh with
working with this kind of data we don't
want to expose anyone uh and it's it can
be really dangerous for their lives to
for that data to be out there
third ask about what you don't know uh
we are not experts on everything but we
can help you if you there are things you
don't know and it's always better to ask
than to assume
something
and i
i wanted to talk a little bit about
machine learning here because i know
most of you
work with algorithms and a run model
some data to predict or to classify or
to do some clustering
or to work with i don't know
processing of another language
my own posture about this my own stance
is that a
it's going to be partial because in a
resolution like this we have only the
side of the victim
that is
80 of what we should know because it's
really important to have the side of the
victim
uh
you have eight more minutes okay
okay so um
[Music]
the the side of editing is very
important but we should have more
information to have the whole picture
and we don't have it
so predicting can have
some troubles and some bias
and i don't know what we should predict
if this if someone is going to be a
victim of
gender-based violence
um so
i'm not sure that
this is safe
for for people to
do
um
especially with the bias data that we
work with usually when we we work with
machine learning we use the data from
society data from twitter or from the
web or reddit
and as we saw on cp3
and
it's it's not going to turn out well
uh so
enough of this we are going to the data
set
uh i think uh some exercises really is
what questions do we want to answer
and our hypothesis to work with this
data the girls are going to give an
intro to pandas inspecting the data with
functions and see what we can find
also that analysis and visualization
it's not going to be um
really hard for people that don't know
anything about this don't worry
um so
it's just like an exploratory data
analysis and see what we can find there
okay
so
i will
stop sharing and put lucy
there thank you and if you have any
questions or anything at all please
say it
so we can
discuss it
yes i'm here
before maybe before starting i i can say
that i have based
all the links that you will need
for following the the workshop here in
the chat so you have a link to
our github
and also you have a collab link so you
can follow the the analysis and also run
the the analysis on on your own
computers so
uh
what i don't know go to
okay
uh cool thank you uh so you you can you
can follow uh all the analysis with in
in your own computer so check the the
links um
let us know
uh okay yeah
that's
it's a good it's good to know that that
you don't have
the the link so here you have the link
to collab i'm sharing it again
um
don't
don't run it in that link
make a copy if you can yes i don't know
when you're going to say that
yeah and also you can check the link to
our
orga in in github so you can also
download the schweiter
notebook
and so you can
locally okay you will you will have the
data missing
maybe but you can check the link if he
has so let's start
we have here the collab as an anivis and
the links
so for this this hand session we have an
overview the first part is how to work
with gender-based violence data that if
we talk about that
then we are going to be uh
to talk about basic intro to python's
libraries and pandas
and then we are going to work with our
data set
loading and inspecting the data
and we are going to do some data
cleaning and data analysis and we are
going to inspect what is happening with
this
data set
so
this
collab is very explicit
you have here our information about the
two communities that we are here
um an explanation about what anna said
before uh eb says before about
gender-based violence and also the
presentation that
she showed us
is here
and i don't know do you want to start
with this basic intro to
libraries
now that we have a lot of time
okay i wasn't expecting this
yeah no maybe just a comment that i i i
think
i'm sure that that you
you have uh the enough knowledge about
the the libraries that we are going to
use but just in case you have a reminded
uh reminder there how to
install or check if those libraries are
there for you so if you are running this
notebook locally uh then you it's it's
it will be nice or or
helpful to check if you have uh this
library
installed so by importing them before
started starting the analysis and then
if you don't have them you can install
them by using pip as as usual so in your
console just type beeping style pandas
or seaborn we are not using
a strange library maybe word cloud or
image could be the
the the strangers but but panda seabourn
i think that you are used to them so
yeah uh please before starting the
analysis if you are running locally
check the
the installation
of all the the
the libraries
yeah
uh
well i don't know
well i think that we are going to skip
this part or not
yeah i don't know if you want to say
something about the intro to pandas
yes just to make to be sure that all of
you know a little bit about pandas this
library maybe we can check in the in the
chat or also with the reactions
i don't know
maybe you can let us know if you need a
refresh
okay we have a some
some okay stir in the reactions
okay
[Music]
i cannot see that but
familiar with with bandage spider all
good
okay nice
cool so maybe we we can just start
checking the
the data
we have
okay we have more comments i will
let's go
okay
perfect so let's go to the loading and
inspecting data part
in this part we are creating two
variables one for the url what is the
data we have this data
and
in the
drive
in
in a specific place but also i think
that is open for all the community
and we are going to read the data using
as usual
pandas read csv
for inspect and inspecting the data we
we can use some
will and functions that
python has
like this
that info
function that you can see the number of
the column the name of the column
if there is some values that is missing
or non-values here and the type of the
body
so in this case
can i say something really quick
um
as you can see we have a lot of
variables regarding violence of gender
based value violence we have physical
violence psychological economical sexual
social
and mental and political environmental
and political so we have the modality we
have the phrases that the a aggressor
told the victim
we have the gender the nationality we
have a lot of of data if you don't know
some of these
terms in spanish there is a translation
document that i will be feeling if you
or you can help me too i will openly
put it to
so you can edit it
so don't be afraid to translate things
yes because as you can see this is a big
data set we have a
71 columns
and also in this case we have
4000 entries 4000 grows so it's a lot of
information and we have as if he says
the date uh
what kind of behavior we have
it is a
gender
based violence what kind of violence
is in this part
if there is one of these violence
and
the gender of the
people is here the age and
this
liberal instruction is how educated is
the person
if how many money
they own and so on
so for take a look of these data sets we
are going to use the head function
so we can take a look of this data
in this contact we have a lot of
different conduct also this is the about
animal protection that in our case is
not important but we are going to see
later how we can filter this column
about behavior
and what else we have here
and
the nationality
and so on
we can also use the describe function in
this described function is very
interesting when we have numerical data
in our data set but in this case we have
only two columns with
numbers that is the number of the
a register and the number of the tom
that this is the number of the
publication of this case
so in this case it's not very
interesting but they can main
for use it in
others
analysis and there is another way to
inspect the data like shape size and
types
so now how we can access to the columns
we can use
the name of the data frame that columns
and you can see the list of all the
names on each column
and also you can access to these columns
passing a list with the names of
different columns in this case we are
using behavior
and
violence and gender-based violence
so
i don't know if there is any comment
until here
no no
okay
and also we can see which are the
unique values or
for every column so we have here the f
and the number the name of the column
and the unique function so you can see
when is
this
gender based violence if there is or is
not of if there is a missing value
there now for accessing to the rows
we can use this function called that
block
so we are filtering here
for each specific rows that is a
with a condition that is
you can use this condition in this case
we want to know
how many rows or which rows are
yes for these gender bias based violence
and we can filter all these data sets
using this
that lock
and we can use also these volume
conditions so we can incarnate two
conditions in this case is the
gender-based violence and the behavior
that is filters but these
this harassment
so we can filter all the data that is
related with harassment and gender based
violence
so this was the first part we are
exploring the data now we are going to
data cleaning and data analysis so for
this specific
analysis we only one
want to work with
the data that is corresponding to the
gender vice violence so we are going to
use
this first filter here
and then we are going to drop in some
duplicate rows
and unnecessary columns
for this dropping unnecessary columns we
are we are going to do first at least
with the names of the columns that we
don't need it
in this case we are using the number of
the registers
and
the scene
and
the
violence gender the gender based
violence because now we know that we are
we only have jazz here
and the others of the
people and where is located these
violence
so
we are going to drop all these columns
and then we have
we can take a look to the new
data set that is called df gender bias
cleanse
and we have this part then we can see
the important things for us like the
resolution date behavior the types of
violence and so on
but also
we can see at the end of this part that
we have a lot of information that we
don't need like these links for example
the
the number of
yes the number of the register and
things like that so we can also use
another way to drop these columns that
is for the number of the index and the
column
and now we have our
data frame clean in this part
we can take a look and this is an
important part because we want to know
what kind of conducts or what kind of
behaviors we have now that we have this
clean
um
data frame
i think that
we need
sorry
yes so we can take a look of this
this is the
unique values for the behavior so we
have here
threads
harassment and
this is
pressure family duties and
damage
abuse
and so on i don't know if eve do you
want to take
yeah no i was just saying that we don't
have a lot of time so we can go to the
visualization part sorry people that
this is how it works
actually i was about to say that we are
kind of cleaning the data in a fast way
because we don't have enough time but as
you can see in the notebook uh we we
should take the the data because the
people who is charging the data the data
entries are maybe could be
the data set is kind of tricky we have
many things to improve so
the the analysis and the the cleaning
data that we are doing here is kind of a
fast
one so
it's just to make it uh work and and
show you which analysis we can do but
but for sure this this part of the
analysis should be improved also it for
a a proper analysis you know okay
uh sorry we have like
40 minutes no
so it's okay
so we don't we have time yeah
okay claudia is saying they're in the
chat
yeah no maybe we we can make some
comments here maybe about the the data
set um
the
the problem we have here in the
collecting data maybe you have any
comments about this
no
this is really good but
the the first data that was gathered in
2006 17 and 18 it's really really dirty
we have a lot of missing values and a
lot of values that i we don't know how
they put it in the data set some dates
of i don't know the the year of the
person that was they they born that
the birth year of the
big team it was a 1900s
so
it's really uh it it was really hard and
we find it all the time with the science
that we have to do a lot of cleaning and
pre-processing to actually
make it prettier and put some variables
together and visualize them
so if we can go a little bit
lucy you can continue yeah no just the
comment was that maybe uh having the
open
the data open is just not enough for
making clear to or accessible to
everyone to uh to analyze the data so
this is the the comment i was
uh
trying to say you know so we have the
data and it's a lot so maybe we can keep
on working on the
this open data could be uh clear enough
for people
to analyze them
so yeah let's continue because yes
because we have like an issue here for
example that is the dates
all the dates you can see that or we
have a lot of missing values
or the dates are in a different
format so it's very difficult to clean
all these die this data or you are
meeting a lot of information here
so yes we only we just not need only
this open
data
we need this data also clean and we need
another
ways to collect this data
also
so in this part we have um
we are just taking a look so
this column that we have with a lot of
missing values so you can check here
what is the values of for these columns
and then we are going to work with the
data we are going to transform the data
for the
resolutions
and
we also rename some columns
and
we can work now with these
kind of violence types
so the important part here as
we are transforming this yes or not in
values for one of zero and then we can
count how many of these difficult
different types of violence we have here
and we can take a look for each year
how is represented as you can see the
one of the big part of this is
psychological violence then swallowing
for physical violence and
then this in green there's the
economical violence and finally the sex
violence
we can see also that we have a peak in
2019
yeah uh one thing we have we should keep
in mind with every other that we work is
that 2020 and 2021 are really strange
years because of the pandemic
and especially in argentina we had a
huge shutdown of everything and lockdown
so people couldn't go to the criminal
court and
it was uh
kind of hard to make these uh claims
about genders based violence
uh but also another thing i wanted to
put out there is that this dataset is
really good because it differentiates
the kinds of violence
when we talk about gender-based violence
it seems like a huge thing but we don't
know what is in it
and we have a lot of forms that violence
can take place
and not it's not only a punch or
something physical
to be violence so
one thing we wanted to tell is that if
you are working with these issues you
should also
search what are the ways in your country
and in your area to
make these claims and if you know
someone that is going through uh this
kind of violence uh you can help them by
a
going with them to some of these courts
or i don't know if the police is the
best place sometimes but
usually you have a a number a whatsapp
so you can make a get help
yeah and you can make a claim yeah also
you can check that this peak also uh is
is overlapped with the uh the
initialization of the pandemic you know
in in 2019 was the the beginning of the
pandemic and here was
was the lockdown in argentina so many
cases the case is raised and that's why
maybe we can see that all the cases also
increased and uh
well we are going to keep on uh with the
analysis so you can check maybe that
some that the reality
what is happening in this in the in the
places or in this case is that
why the the lockdown is um increasing
the cases also so yeah as as
evie said
you have uh you
you may check
the the lines or the telephone numbers
that you can call in case that you are
uh
under
this violence cases or whatever check in
argentina for example we have
144 and lou i think that you also have a
line there in colombia so checking your
country and
don't don't be afraid to ask for help
talk
yes
uh here we have uh a question
did all claims drop
or just those related to gender
uh all of them okay if he is kind of
uh answering in the chat maybe we can we
can read also the the questions and the
answers here so the record will will
have
the answers and the questions yeah i was
saying that we can check it
when we finish this notebook if we have
a little bit of time or you can do it
yourself now you can check how many uh
claims or resolutions were in 2020
and compare it with the rest of the
years
so we are taking a look to the type of
violence and now we want to know what is
the age of the victim or the defense
so we also have a part for cleaning all
the data as you know this is a
issue to improve because we have
different formats
for the edge
and then
we can see
sorry there is a song
yeah there is a make open i think that
maybe there's no
it can't
help us or maybe it's desmond
itself okay now it's it's okay
no yeah just to to say that as you can
as you can see we have
kind of solved the dates that we have
there because the the the that uh was
uh written in many or different ways
that that was what we were talking about
before that maybe
this is something to improve the first
step is asking for the open data and the
second step is to make it
clear enough to to make all the the
analysis so this is something that we we
were talking about before and also again
we we were kind of of
trying to filter and make this in a in a
fast way but
for sure you can improve also this this
kind of filtering by using regular
expressions or whatever and i'm i might
and improve the analysis
yeah
yes and also we need to be sure about
the data is correct because we have like
wrong numbers here
so we can take a look of this edge and
we have this
the age for them
sorry
the big team
so we can take a look at the edge of the
victim and we have this distribu
distribution and we can see that is
also
the big one peak
is between 20s and 30s like 25
and the second peak is
around 30
35 years
so is like almost people of our age
that is suffering a lot of violence
and this is a something strange because
i see this
distribution
for the
the defendant
and you can see that we have more young
people here
usually
when we take a look to the gender of
this
victim and defendant we have women here
and
men here
so
we need also the right
data to take a real analysis of this
this part
yeah
maybe it's just a comment that i was uh
saying in the chat not for for not
interrupting you lou but again uh we we
need to check uh
carefully
if the data missing that we are removing
or whatever is representative or not we
we we were trying to work with the
columns or the rows that
that have less missing data so
and as just a comment about the the the
plot that you were talking about lou as
we can see this problematic or the
is kind of
spread in all the ages so we have some
peaks but the this is a problematic that
that we have for all the
the ages and so this is something to to
keep in mind
yes
and also we can take a look to the
violins events for year so you can see
how we filtered in this part
of the dates
for the when it happened this event when
was they in the uh
the beginning of this event or the end
of the event and also the day of
resolution
so we can go
to this part
so we have here the
number of cases
and here we have in this access we have
the days
until the resolution
i don't know if ev if you want to
explain a little bit what means these
days until the resolution
yeah uh usually when some
violence happens in the household or in
the public
arena
the incident happens
and
they go through the court and it's a
long process uh we usually don't know
how long it's going to be and it's
really uh
we can see here it's really really long
and sometimes exhausting and time
consuming and resource consuming
but it's worth it but
the
the average is a year
since the the incident happened until
the resolution of the judge
so it's a long process here in argentina
at least maybe in some other places it's
faster
and in some other places maybe slower
too and we can see that we have some uh
resolutions that it took almost four
years no or more so it's really really
wrong process
um
yeah this this could be exhausting for
the victims and that's why maybe some
some victims
don't want to to
to start this this kind of process so
uh this is something maybe to to change
and this is why this kind of analysis
worth it
because we can we can check
how hard is for the victims and how how
hard is the
to to ask
or or to to have a a resolution or
a
solution for the problems
with the system like it is right now
yeah also on until in the chat something
really really interesting is that maybe
we should check if the age distribution
is similar to the other claims
so maybe younger people go more often to
court because here in argentina and also
in america the the movement of women for
their rights is really really strong in
the in the few last few years
so
a lot of young people are really
conscious about uh what to do in
situations they are well informed and
they are not as afraid maybe as some
other people that maybe they have kids
together they live together they have a
hard situation in the if they are a
couple
and so
for some people with when kids are
involved when their life stakes involve
like if you if you depend on your
husband for a living and you live in
their house
it's it's hard to to make these claims
so that's that's one of our hypothesis
and assumptions we can't be wrong but
all the
theory says it's it's going to be like
this too no and also
also uh the in the in the young age
maybe could be difficult to
to
to know
what we are going through if we have no
education about it so here in argentina
we have some laws for for uh
having this
gender and sex education in at the
school but maybe it's not that common or
it is still not working enough and so
it's kind of
difficult for the young
people to
to know if they are going through
balance or not so if they should claim
or not so this is also something to to
check
yeah each time we
encounter a new variable or a clause of
variables we have to keep in mind a lot
of things regarding gender-based
violence
so we don't jump to any early
conclusions
or we don't understand fully what is
going on here
yes this i think that this is an
invitation for the people that you can
take a look more deeply
to this notebook to this data and also
try to answer these
questions that we have here and
and solve these processes yes
with other data related or uh
sociological or the the local data so
you can cross information and make the
the
uh a new hypothesis or or to make clear
the things yeah
because this for example this result we
have here the average of the time for
the resolution is
346 days
is almost a year for a resolution so if
we find these results we can also
propose something for the political
public politicals or something like that
this but we need data and we need
results
and also understand these results
so this was the
yes the distribution for the days until
the resolution of the problem the
problem
uh well this is a detail of that
and then we are going to take a look to
these gender-based violence behavior so
we can take a look to this part so we
can count how many times for this
behavior we have
any of these
types so
we have these traits
so it's three
three hundred times
a harassment 100 times and these race of
family duties and um
damage and so on
so
then
we can take a look also to the gender of
the persons so we have here
one small thing
yes and if you see that the threads and
the harassing are the the big part of
the
of their behaviors
it's similar with the
psychological violence that people
suffer so
threats and harassment usually don't
have like a physical
consequence they they
are not explicit
sexual or physic violence
but it's a the most common kind of
violence
because it starts with this
psychological violence and and the
the man saying a lot of horrible things
and doing a lot of horrible stuff that
are not physical to restrain the victim
and then
sometimes it leads to physical violence
not every time but sometimes and it's
not
we don't have to wait until the physical
violence to make a claim
we can do it before that
yes also we can see here that we have
this street
uh sexual harassment
and
yes
and we have a lot of conducts
behaviors
and i was saying that we have also we
can filter these data set by the gender
so we have the first one is the gender
of the defendant
so we can see that the
most of the people is men cis men
and the gender of the victim is uh women
yeah and also one analysis you can do if
you have a little bit of time if we have
a little bit of time
after the notebook is to see
how many of these
people have kids together have children
together and see
the the conduct the third conduct is
about family duties i don't know you've
seen if you can go a little bit up
so they are not
doing their family duties and so a women
go to court for that so
usually that's when we they have
children together and the man is not
uh paying the money or yeah
yeah paying the the
the food or the
scholarships or whatever for for the
kids so
so if someone wants to try and do this
intersection between kids
and the the palabria the wording in in
spanish is ejo
if they have together and see about
these claims
it's interesting
yes
so we filter here the
by the
a gender of the victim that is women
and also what is the kind of behavior
and we have here how is the frequency
the number of cases so also
we have the same that before
so we have the
dreads the harassment these brains of
family duties the
damage and so on
and
we also have these that this is very
interesting is how many
times
happens this violence uh physical
violence uh psychological violence
physical violence economical violence
sexual violence
this is for symbolic maybe
yes so
you can see all the the violence and you
can see where it happened
[Music]
yeah maybe this is important to to be
related with the plot that we were
looking before
looking at before uh about the the
pandemic and when it the case is racist
because as you can check here as this is
a hitman that that as uh evie was about
to say that
the the hot spots or the the the brown
spots that you have there are the the
bigger the
the biggest uh
numbers so
as you can see all the all the or the
most of the cases or the disappearance
okay happens in the at home
so that's maybe could be a reason why
when uh since the pandemic started and
the lockdown started all the cases
raised so this is something that maybe
we can put together
like a small pieces together with the
the blood we did before
yeah and also uh
gender-based violence usually it's
called also domestic violence we don't
do that because there is a huge uh
spectrum of violence but
the domestic violence is really really
common
and as you can see the second one is on
the public road
harassment or fights or whatever on the
bottom road and the third one is on the
internet
technological medium so internet
whatsapp a harassment via online that
it's a hugely increasing nowadays
and it's a felony and it's something
that we should um some countries don't
even have a legislation for it
uh so if there is violence in in the
internet or harassment in the internet
you should keep all the evidence and you
can go to a small claims court or
criminal court and
make that claim
um
it's interesting because
when we think about gender-based
violence we think about it in physical
and confrontational face-to-face
and some
it is increasing the number of conflicts
on in the internet nowadays and we can
see that here
no i'm also talking about this as as the
the
since the pandemic start started and we
started or many people we maybe we we
did it before but many people started
working on on the web and kids are now
having the their classes online or
whatever and so this is something that
maybe could be interesting to to show
that
we need education so we can prevent and
we can know when we are
suffering
this kind of balance and so this is
important showing data and showing these
results could be important for for make
governments or or schools or wherever to
to
to
start talking about this problematics
and so the kids also can kids women or
everyone can know when is going through
this kind of situation so yeah oh here
we have another event
is there any data that shows the cause
of some of these
violences
even um yeah
look at it in a sociological point of
view
and see that the
violence it's a
social phenomenon that happens because
men are raised to believe that they are
better and
smarter and stronger than women
and that women are objects that should
be used to have children and to serve
men
i think this is a simplistic a
a conclusion
but
uh it's much more complex than that it's
a patriarchal system as an assessed
the violence is not
i don't think we can see it in the data
i don't know what a the rest of the
people in this workshop think
uh
yeah but i was
sorry i was thinking about this of the
causes of this violence and maybe
something that we can ask
at the beginning of these
forms of when the people is going to do
this um
how is the name for denunciates
let me claim
claim yes maybe we need more information
about that so we can
take a look to these hypotheses
no yeah
think
yeah sorry
it's dangerous to think that the cause
of the violence comes from this data
because this data comes from the woman
so
it's kind of saying that the woman is
guilty of the violence because she had
children with the
with the accused or she
i don't know didn't work or whatever
so
it's it's dangerous to make those
assumptions it's really
intricate in the society how we blame
women for everything
and um
it's important to see that there is much
more than this data set to understand
gender-based violence so we need to read
and research and talk
yeah
this is something that maybe we
we need to to to make it clear because
we are women working in women
communities and so we we we know that
this this
is
common and this is a complex
problem that we we all can solve
together and it is needed to be solved
by all
so the the first part is
thinking this problem not in a linear
way not in a just a
cause reaction just thinking that this
is a sociological problem as evie said
and it's a complex problem so so we can
blame people we just need to analyze
deeply and and think about how the
system uh the patriarchal system and how
capitalism
is also affecting this so the work the
people have maybe we can recommend you
some texts and um and also
reading about this and how in the
sociological asp the the sociological
aspects and how this could be analyzed
also can help for this analysis as you
know analyzing data
involves uh
knowing about the domain that we are
analyzing so here the domain is kind of
complex and we need to to know that it
is not something uh lineal and that that
we we can just say okay this is the
cause and this is the reaction no it's
not that easy so
yeah
but also
in the
sorry
in the in the summary of our notebook i
was going to make a little small
reflection about
we are not going to change chainer-based
violence analyzing data
we just going we are going to understand
it better but our goal is not to solve
it be a data science because we can't
but we can understand it we can push
governments and a
society to be better
via data that's why we do it
yes i was thinking about the what with
kind of what kind of question are
important at the moment that you are
collecting these
a question when you are doing the claim
so what else what what what other kind
of information we need for let's start
these data analysis also
now if we go a little bit
to the work cloud we can also see
understand it better because
this data set has something that is
really valuable
um
yes
it's the the the
the phrases that the
aggressor said to the victim
it's really really strong and it has a
lot of really hard language and
bad words
but
you can hear
the the violence in those phrases
and we made a small world crowd that
it's not cute it's really awful but
you'll see if you can show it
uh it's in spanish so people don't
understand spanish but the bigger one is
i'm going to kill you that's the the
main phrase that aggressor says is i'm
going to kill you death threats are
really really common
um
shut up shut up and i'm going to
you because you're sleeping with someone
in
kill
else
so uh
and
uh so that's one of the word class we
created the other one is about the words
not the phrases
no
yes it's the words of the behaviors
the behaviors and there there was one
more or no
no
okay so that was the
um yeah so mainly and what we wanted to
do is to see what was happening
in this particular criminal court and to
see what kind of conducts they are
charging people with
and the phrases they are
the the
the
the kids are using
so
um
that's uh the video info networks anna i
will send you yeah i i no i i was trying
to answer a claudia that is asking us
for a slack chat so we can share
information data and and
books maybe you can follow us yeah we
have a slack that that's something that
i i was uh
we have a slack for pi data with
everyone in this conversation this is a
channel with analyze gender-based
violence in this workshop so i will uh
put everything there
no and also was about to say that with
that agenda and also with
wbds
la we are all all the time doing some
workshops and
and inviting people that are working in
this kind of of
problematics and so
we are giving some free
workshops that you can join and
and please
follow us and be part of our
our proposals because this is important
to to keep in mind the whole uh
scenario of this problematic and so you
can join us in any other
uh
workshops or talks that we organize uh
yeah also thank you if you
started doing your own analysis of this
data set and you want to show us some of
the things you found and the graphics
you made and the visualizations or every
anything
in the slack channel of my data we can
do it ando you told us a lot of things
we can do and i encourage you to do it
and if you can later we can schedule a
call and and and make something
else of this
so
we are open to any suggestions i hope
you had a good time
although the subject is kind of hard to
deal with
and that everything was understood
and yeah if you have any question or you
have any suggestion or you do you want
to collaborate or whatever please
contact contact us and we we will be
happy to have you
uh in our communities too uh
claudia she's answering spanish yeah
this month is desperate week because we
need to break
yeah
thank you very much um
our panelists uh we would have to break
to the god out of town now um if you
have any questions just as they said you
can move over to slack and continue the
discussion over there and informations
and other resources are going to be
available to you guys all day thank you
all for being around here so let's split
to um the gadado town if if you are
confused about where to find a link
check in the announcement section
uh check sorry in
the general session let's paste that
there you should be able to access it
thank you so bye
thank you everyone